in a world where plundering overlords
have run amok the exploited masses
turned a one man to save them they
ruined his state and now somewhere
somehow someone's gonna pay
unfortunately the fantasy ends there
Arnold Schwarzenegger is rain is
California Governor turned into a
disaster flick that could spell
catastrophe for the Golden State and the
whole nation funny thing is it all
started out so well when i get the
sacramento I would immediately destroy
the car tags when governor gray davis
raised the car tax Californians were
already among the highest tax people in
the nation and Davis had just finished a
giant spending spring the governor even
ignored some easy ways to help plug the
massive budget deficit believe it or not
this golf course is owned by the state
of California why not sell it and sell
this stadium these fairgrounds in this
Malibu beach home where MTV once hosted
a spring break special don't forget to
check out the grind is up next and I
allysin chaynes so check it out
Californians were already tired of
politicians who kept demanding more from
them while refusing to do any belt
tightening of their own so watch what's
gonna happen over there the cart X was
simply the final insult hasta la vista
baby for the car dogs he would stay true
to his work towards a [ __ ] pummeled
dozens of candidates including Gray
Davis Gary Coleman me major in a porno
star when 2003's historically wacky
recall election I'll be back The
Terminator transformed into the
governator and promptly smashed the car
tax it was the perfect political
superhero the charm of Harry Tasker the
brains of julius benedict with twins and
of course the muscle to make good on his
promise to rescue Californians from
spend happy politicians arnold
schwarzenegger simply lied to them it
comes down to that Tom McClintock was a
California State Senator wen
Schwarzenegger won the governor's race
he even ran against Arnold if you have
the credit Constance rode away so that
our politicians can never ever do that
again he promised to cut up the credit
cards live within our means never ever
spent more money than to take in he did
exactly the opposite Schwarzenegger
increased spending faster than we saw
under gray davis but why if ever there
was someone powerful enough to
bending it was Arnold turns out there's
a force in California politics that's
much stronger than the governing we're
twisting arms with threatening people on
this day a teacher's union president was
rallying his troops in Los Angeles to
try to stop proposed cuts to teachers
jobs two weeks earlier other unions were
at the same location fighting against
proposed layoffs to other school staff
these are hardworking people i'm one of
them hard-working people they're trying
to put it off in the street you know
what no don't let the Terminator
catchphrase fool you they're not fans of
Schwarzenegger that woman hasn't
reformed him a tiny bit yo he's an actor
and he'll always be an actor handy would
that good of an actor I Canady she
should be ashamed of herself June is the
divorce at full or smacking into the
middle of next week unions have smacked
sports & Eggar around quite a bit in
2005 the governor challenged unions with
the slate of propositions including one
that aimed to restrain state spending
the union's United in 2005 and they
showed Arnold where to shove his
proposition Schwarzenegger propositions
were obliterated when he came against
the Union the Union showed them where
the real acting came in rally like this
is quite a production there are
producers who come up with a game plan
the organizers have meetings at working
eight their political analysts and
whatever they decide what the best
course of action is there are directors
with bullhorns and of course actors
acting comes in with us people who are
in who are unionized check in grab a
ready-made sign and learn your lines
to print it on sheets for your
convenience so much screaming and
yelling but it's all organized screaming
and yelling I need you to stay longer
and scream and yell and carry on the
public employee unions have been acting
in their own self-interest to plunder
the Treasury of the state and they've
done a very good job of it how good well
the state keeps hiring more workers
today California State workforce is
larger than the population of st. Louis
and tens of thousands earned six figure
income maybe you're surprised at the
Union success after all it seems like
their programs are always getting cut
education funding is make any cut left
and right what's been happening to
education funding in recent years it's
been cut well you know that's propaganda
the spending for education has been
steadily increasing despite the fact
that for at least the last three years
the student population in the state
spend in decline California spends quite
a bit on teachers they're the highest
paid in the nation in overall state
spending has exploded under
Schwarzenegger but that's just what
governments do just as the Terminator
was programmed to find Sarah Connor
government is programmed to grow and
grow and grow and fight every effort to
cut it back why is that because
government concentrates its benefits and
diffuses the costs here's what he means
say California politicians are
considering a five hundred million
dollar bill to give raises to state
worker it's a lot of money but since the
total cost is spread across so many
taxpayers you as an individual taxpayer
only have to pay a tiny amount say five
cents the taxpayer is getting dinged for
the five cents really has no no serious
motivation to go out and get active
would you spend all day protesting over
a lousy five cents and that's why
government almost always grows bigger
whenever there's a proposal that would
boost spending the group that would
benefit mounts an organized effort to
fight for it meanwhile taxpayers just
shrug at the added nickel but as all of
those nickels begin to accumulate and
begin to drag down
the economy people begin to sense that
the society is seriously off track put
yourself in the shoes of a politician is
up for reelection even if you think the
state spends too much would you really
want to oppose these people keep on
opposing cuz you know what we're gonna
come after you next one step at a time
far better to have this highly organized
production on your side contributing to
your campaign with money and volunteers
we walk volunteer our butts off we
telephone bank we go to these rallies
just six years after state legislators
nearly spent California into oblivion
the states on the verge of going broke
after yet another spending spring but
guess what politicians have to say about
their super-sized budgets we've cut away
the fat we've come eat and frankly we're
at the bones remember she nor colleagues
still own that golf course that Malibu
beach house they're spending record
amounts of dough so what's with all the
talk about cuts cuts are going to be
made the only question is whether those
cuts are made in family budgets through
higher taxes or they're made in
government budgets through lower
spending so guess who was forced to do
the belt-tightening governor
schwarzenegger is proposing a huge tax
hike to help close a growing hole in the
state budget Sacramento politicians
passed the tax hike in February 2009
squeezing another eleven hundred dollars
from the average family McClintock says
it's inevitable that spending binge
'it's lead to tax hikes spending can can
only be done by extracting money from
the economy he was either done by
taxation or stun by borrowing which
ultimately has to be repaid by taxation
in 2008 state senator McClintock became
US congressman McClintock when the newly
minted representative arrived in
Washington Republicans were still
hungover from their record spending
binge then Democrats took over and
quickly tried to outdo the GOP
McClintock worries that the Golden State
offers a preview of coming attractions
for a real-life disaster flick that's
headed for our country I think if you
want to know where our country is
heading under Barack Obama you only need
to look to California years of
unsustainable spending followed by heavy
taxes and regulations as destroyed
California's economy whether in
Sacramento of Washington unions fight to
direct more tax dollars to themselves
and of course so Duke bankers corporate
CEOs and countless other special
interest groups degeneration ago
California spending far less per capita
inflation-adjusted than we're spending a
day had the finest of a public school
system in the country we were offering a
free university education every
Californian have wanted one we had the
finest highway system in the world but
now things are worse even though taxes
are higher you are not going to like
this remember the car tax hasta la vista
baby for the cob dogs more like hasta
LaVista to that promise because the car
tax is back it'll cost individual
drivers hundreds sometimes thousands of
dollars as high taxes high borrowing and
high spending destroy California's
economy Californians are moving to those
49 other states if we allow the same
policies to destroy our country where
are we going to go good question
congressman McClintock does think we can
turn things around and here's hoping
he's right but if a powerful force of
nature like Arnold Schwarzenegger gets
so bludgeoned by big government what
hope do mere mortals have